I'm Val altunin on the scientific
illustrator here at science alright yeah
typically mondays or when the
assignments come in and that's when I
really do all the preliminary research
and just try to wrap my head around
what's going on here and refresh my
memory about the standard textbook stuff
that's related to it
the article in particular was about
membrane proteins so I started sketching
and trying to think of how a membrane
with some proteins in it would look
across two pages and work with with the
text on the page Tuesday is when I
really start attacking the actual
rendering of the illustration will use
cinema 4d for our 3d work and there's a
plugin called EP MV embedded Python
molecular viewer that is the thing that
reads those x-ray defraction files and
interprets them in 3d geometry there is
a G couple protein receptor and we had
the contact from the lab that discovered
the structure of this particular one so
we got in contact with them to get the
diffraction data specifically of that
protein that very proteins so he sent it
to me which was really helpful I loaded
it into my program and there it was on
the screen
Wednesday is just work day is plugging
away at it space and time just don't
exist I'm so focused and then I also am
able to collaborate with people which is
also it's always fun and exhilarating
because you get to voice your own
opinion hear other people's opinion and
consider why it differs from your own
it's really important in the creative
process all that discovery that happens
I look at it and in a graph I actually
drew a little graph my perceive skill
and my actual skill follow a repeatable
trend my actual skill will it'll
increase in the narrow plateau then
it'll increase in an old plateau and in
those plateau moments might perceive
still plummets because I notice myself
plateauing little by little the
improvements happen on Thursday
I got comments back and made revisions
the biggest piece of art direction that
we got on that was that it I think it
needs more sparkle so I had to get back
and and survey what sparkles means
and Friday is when the magazine is
delivered I ended up making it very
reflective very glassy very bright cyan
membrane which I thought was pretty
extreme but it actually it actually
looks pretty nice I'm gonna spread and
so he's good there's a good decision
you
things that people threw away a hundred
years ago or in many ways just as
mysterious as the things that people
threw away in ancient Egypt three four
or five thousand years ago because often
what people see they do and what they
actually do are two very very different
things so the students who are
excavating at Roosevelt Park are
focusing on the private areas of
household activities all right let's get
to work